i want to play for you he specifically
talks about an aspect of the matrix
calling up his ex-girlfriends throughout
this process that i found fascinating
tyler this is at 3303 if we can play
that and then rolla we'll get your
reaction to that
we're just going to fast forward this is
the brother too i hadn't seen this one
the [ __ ] is wrong with you
you know the thing is though grow up but
the thing is you know what's crazy the
matrix has tried this so and then in the
height of the media storm against me
after they silenced me about 15 of my
ex-girlfriends were called contacted
were contacted by reporters saying you
have anything bad to say by andrew do
you think about the same andrew now
if i wasn't a gentleman because these
are all ex-girlfriends they have no
reason to protect me they all called me
andrew these people are out to get you
this is unfair that i'd never turn on
you you were so nice to me you're such a
good man not a single woman turned on me
ksi is out here with women talking about
how he makes someone comfortable talk
about rape face i don't have a single
woman who's come forward saying i've
done anything bad to them in fact only
the contrary i have endless women coming
forward saying i'm a nice man not a
single woman has come forward and said i
have hurt them or have done anything bad
to them not a single one even when they
were offered money to lie about me they
still wouldn't do it whereas ksi's
sitting here with things like this out
in the open he's not canceled true
geordi is clearly a sexual deviant he
isn't canceled ethan is saying the
things he's saying which we already
talked about him being a racist and a
sexist misogynist he ain't canceled and
everyone's gonna sit number ten they
cancel me because i'm a misogyny i don't
want to [ __ ] lie i don't want so this
was i i thought
very compelling um i'm not surprised
that they called his of course not they
wanted to get somebody on record you
know the hunger of the machine i could
just see it let's get him this is the
moment let's call all his ex-girlfriends
you could just see they were they were
really jazzed up on that suspicion
i want your thoughts on that but also i
have to say his coverage of the ksi i
didn't know much about ksi but at true
george i was laughing i lost it i mean i
really lost it because he was he was
saying
something very valid which is like why
am i banned but these people are over
here doing all this kind of stuff and
that's totally okay why the double
standard and i think the answer is
obvious that his influence was deemed to
be much larger and hence more
problematic but go ahead give me your
reaction i i made this observation on
yesterday's show about him uh
i
just recently i think it was just this
week uh a twit i think she's twitch
twitch streamer i think her name is
adriana chechik or something like that
she was basically having sex on twitch
right just in flagrant violation of the
of the user thing she gets a seven day
suspension
that's it
and like but here's you know tate's like
what did i do
it's not okay you have to remember like
when we're talking about the matrix and
we're talking about like because that's
it's an abstract term it could be
whatever you want it to be but this
system right
um you have to remember
that the system is still people that are
in the system so when say for example i
used joe rogan not too long ago uh you
say well joe rogan went over to spotify
he made 100 million dollars and now uh
his some of his old archived videos are
getting deleted because uh the system
wants uh to delete his interviews with
jordan peterson or with um i know stefan
mullin whoever it is right because they
don't like the guy that they had on
there and they don't want that in the
archive in the library and maybe maybe
joe cares maybe he doesn't but the fact
is is that that decision is made by
people is made by the ideology of the
people the emotionalism of the people
who can press the backspace button and
delete that you know permanently delete
yes you know
um so it's you have to remember that
that just because we're talking about
big tech and we we tend to see them as
each juggernauts or these like
impenetrable you know big tech kind of
things they're run by people
zuckerberg is a person okay uh uh
what's to say uh jack dorsey is a person
okay whoever's making the decisions
that's spotify to do those things
whoever's decided that we're gonna
collectively ban andrew tate and any of
his sub channels on tick tock a person
did that a person said you know what
this is so dangerous and it grates
against everything that i ideologically
philosophically you know think that i'm
going to press the backspace button here
so it's not just this
this we i think as human beings we tend
to want to find the other the enemy the
outside like illuminati or the the cult
of moloch worshiping baby eating jeffrey
epstein island going you know illuminati
that's in control you know good puppet
masters and everything those people are
still human beings they're still have
this ideology there's so they're
programming it's their
whatever they're still responding to
what you and i respond to as human
beings as well and so you have to take
that element into consideration when
you're criticizing the system when
you're criticizing the matrix because
they just have a power that you don't
have so when somebody like say for
instance like what if a guy like andrew
tate gets into that system and now he's
the one that's making the decisions on
who gets deleted and who doesn't get
deleted uh i've made this observation
before that everyone you know is a
social justice warrior it just depends
on what your idea and what your your
definition of justice happens to be
i think that's a fantastic point looking
at it from more of a human level because
it is true when you talk about the
system or the matrix you tend to see it
as like aliens or something like it's
it's removed from your identity it's the
evil it's the evil others
and we want because we want to have that
we want to have an enemy that's like
greater than ourselves to sort of go up
against and bro the problem with this is
because people ask me all the time don't
you think feminism was a result of the
jews or the the uh the rockefellers or
this this these vested interests and
everything i go well they were probably
there like certainly there was
commercial interests that were there
like johnny on the spot to make sure
that they were going to profit off of
those social movements but the answer to
that question is no it's us right it's
just who we are this is what we are as
human beings and you put us in this
situation whether it's technology or
society or whatever you put us into
those environments and we're gonna
humans are gonna act like humans and and
by the way the same conversation applies
people often vilify government i do it's
i can't stand big government but it's
like they forget that government is just
a bunch of bureaucrats it's just a bunch
of people it's not it's not a building
and when the vaccine mandates came down
i always reminded people like there are
people enforcing this and in places like
new york city oftentimes it also became
law enforcement that was going around
and yanking people out of stores so you
have to be able to hold people
accountable for their actions as people
as well you don't just get to blame an
institution end of story um that that's
much easier
right exactly i was just following order
as i ripped you out of you you're a 10
year old and i ripped you out of a store
eating a sandwich because you didn't
have a vaccine card yeah i didn't have a
lot of patience for that as you might
imagine
so i watch this i can i throw something
out really quickly this is really great
series it's on apple tv but it's called
five days at memorial and it's about the
the hurricane katrina disaster and it's
like the the memorial the hospital that
the stories that went on the hospital in
the you know they had to do euthanasia
and all this other stuff that was going
on because
because the people who were working at
in the system who are working in the
hospital system were just so dependent
on that system that even in a life or
death environment where they were like
you know what all bets are off man it's
it's like every man for himself
even under that system there's stuff to
like write scripts out for like you know
morphine or
they're still hoping that corporate is
gonna send helicopters right right
they're still hoping that the system is
going to to work for them five days in
people dying and it's just like it's a
third world country and they're still
thinking that the people who are in
texas or who are in the corporate uh you
know the corporate world are gonna send
help and that they've got some sort of
emergency plan that's already
established and nobody did right and so
now they're they're still waiting and
people are dying because they're
dependent on that system if you like the
short clip you can catch another one
here or you can catch the full episode
right here
[Music]
you